the storm is still causing trouble north
of Boston where a commuter train
derailed this morning there are no
reports of injuries coastal areas didn't
get as much snow but strong winds and
high water did cause significant damage
there flooding is reported from
Maryland's Chesapeake Bay to New York
Long Island and into New England DeMarco
Morgan is on the coast in Duxbury
Massachusetts where entire neighborhoods
are under water right now DeMarco good
morning good morning the flooding has
gotten worse since overnight the streets
are flooded here in this area and the
snow is falling down a nun stopped a
nearby seawall here in Duxbury actually
split open during last week's nor'easter
leaving all of these homes all too
vulnerable powerful swells crashed into
an already crippled seawall water
spilled into neighborhoods and covered
yards the walls themselves are close to
70 years old and they're just they've
run its course and Fire Chief Kevin Nord
says he and his team have gone
door-to-door urging people to evacuate
go further inland go go stay at on
sally's or something and some some
higher ground and and place where they
have electricity with you but away from
the coast
the storm knocked out power to more than
400,000 New Englanders heavy snow caused
headaches for drivers it's a mess out
here get off the road and buried some
communities under as much as two feet
emergency crews worked through the night
struggling to keep up with the storms
relentless pace we're falling a little
behind because we got guys scattered
everywhere we'll be doing this till
tomorrow afternoon
now New England is not out of the clear
just yet this region is under a winter
storm warning until late this afternoon
and by the time it's over with Vermont
will have received more than three feet
of snow
as for Duxbury here when we talk about
that seawall it could take up to five to
ten days to patch it up completely
Nora really rough for them there DeMarco
thank you so much